oi boa tarde eu gostaria que vocês
deixassem os olhos ou não tanto faz que
a critério de vocês mas eu gostaria que
vocês pensassem agora quais são os
principais problemas ambientais que nós
temos hoje quando a gente fala em
problema ambiental que vem na cabeça de
vocês
e já pensaram
e já agora eu queria que quem pensa em
mudanças climáticas levanta a mão legal
muito de vocês deve ter pensado na
questão do desmatamento ou esgotamento
dos recursos naturais legal eu tenho
certeza que alguns de vocês pensaram na
questão da poluição e contaminação do ar
do solo ou das nossas águas e
é a grande maioria levanta a mão deve
ter pensado na problemática dos resíduos
dos 80 milhões de toneladas que só o
brasil gera por ano claro que alguns de
vocês deve ter pensado também na perda
da nossa nossas espécies os outros
animais e das milhares de espécies que
estão entrando em extinção
é mas o que você fez perguntar para
vocês é o seguinte qual a principal
causa desses problemas ambientais
bom então eu acho que eles vão concordar
comigo quando eu falo que o principal
motivo desse problemas ambientais é o
nosso padrão de produção e consumo ou
seja o grande problema ambiental é o
estilo de vida da nossa sociedade vocês
concordam
e esse é o grande creme dental e daí eu
fiquei tentando resolver esse problema
quebrando a cabeça dias e dias tentando
entender e achar uma solução na minha
cabeça era tão simples e o grande
problema ambiental é o estilo de vida da
sociedade porque a gente não muda o
estilo de vida ou está dificuldade isso
oi e daí eu mudei a pergunta a maria por
que você não muda seu estilo de vida
olá eu sou engenheiro ambiental
pós-graduado em direito ambiental tem
diversas especialidades na área
ambiental trabalha há quase 10 anos no
mercado e mesmo assim há um ano e meio
atrás eu não era um grande exemplo de
uma vida sustentável
oi e daí eu fiquei pensando eu fiquei
analisando qual era a dificuldade na
minha rotina qual era a dificuldade na
vida da minha família dos meus amigos eu
fiz inúmeras pesquisas e número de
entrevistas e eu entendi uma coisa do
brasil a china pode passar para os
estados unidos vocês quiserem as pessoas
estão preocupadas com os problemas do
dia a dia delas o que quer dizer elas
estão preocupadas como vou pagar as
contas no final do mês elas estão
preocupadas entregar o trabalho que o
professor quer que seu chefe quer elas
estão preocupados em resolver as
questões de relacionamento
eu estou depois disso algumas delas se
preocupam com as questões ambientais
quem sabe que foi o mais interessante
que eu descobri essa pesquisa que a
maioria delas ou quase todas elas
esperam que as soluções sejam fácil
acessível e atrativa
oi e daí eu consegui entender aonde nós
estávamos errando que não conseguimos
influenciar o estilo de vida das pessoas
para resolver os problemas ambientais
e a comunicação
e tem um grande problema que a gente não
deixa claro o que que é sustentabilidade
eu acho não explica para as pessoas para
ver se sustentar você tem que olhar
assim a questão econômica a questão
social ea questão ambiental que tem que
se sustentar por um longo período
ah e tem um outro problema talvez é o
principal nós técnicos da área ambiental
nós somos muito técnicos e um pouco chá
é né a gente não é chato porque a gente
quer mas sim porque a gente sabe da
urgência que precisa essa questão
ambiental
é mas toda vez que eu chegava para falar
sobre sustentabilidade ou sobre a
questão ambiental ou a maioria dos
profissionais da área ambiental tenho
certeza que era recebido com essa cara
eu lavei eu de novo falando da questão
dental lá vem ela de novo querendo que a
gente mude
e ele estava pensando maria se você quer
então ajudar a mudar o estilo de vida
das pessoas você precisa encontrar uma
forma de ser leve fácil atrativo e
acessível e foi aí que eu criei um
projeto xeque-mate eco tem um projeto
meu pequeno instagram que eu dou 365
dicas eco uma dica por dia de como você
pode ser mais sustentável no seu dia a
dia então se vocês assim como eu não
consegue ainda colocar todo o seu nicho
o seu resíduo dentro de um potinho
durante um ano não tem problema você
pode talvez trocar as lâmpadas a sua
casa de como um por led e tem uma
eficiência energética melhor você pode
por um arejador na torneira e diminuir o
consumo de água ou você pode talvez
incentivar algum projeto socioambiental
e contribuir mensalmente com um bom
projeto
o ou você pode escolher as 365 dias que
eu posso dar para vocês vocês não
esqueci não esperar se 100% sustentar
vocês podem começar agora sendo
sustentável
e eu descobri nessa caminhada que o
equilíbrio de tudo isso não é algo fixo
e é algo dinâmico é a rotina da minha
vida é a rotina da vida de vocês
eu e nessa vida a gente precisa
encontrar um equilíbrio sustentável
então agora eu quero mesmo ser feche os
olhos dessa vez dessa vez é de verdade e
e eu quero que vocês pensem o dia de
vocês
e quais as cores que vocês estão fazendo
o quê que você escolhe colocar dentro da
sua casa o que você escolhe colocar
dentro do seu corpo o que você escolhe
pensar o que você escolhe sentir será
que você não consegue ter uma vida mais
equilibrada será que você não consegue
ter uma vida mais sustentável
só podem abrir os olhos se vocês vão
pensar em nada eu tô aqui pra ajudar
vocês com cinco dicas bem fáceis e
rápidos e saírem hoje sendo um pouco
mais eco a primeira saiba a origem do
produto que vocês compram que vocês
consomem nós precisamos incentivar o
comércio local e precisamos incentivar o
produtor local a maioria dos produtos
que a gente compra geralmente da china e
isso tem uma grande problemática
ambiental pelas emissões atmosféricas ou
talvez um trabalho escravo ou talvez por
uma legislação bem só que não é cumprida
thomas precisamos saber quem faz da onde
vem e como veio a melhor maneira de
incentivar gerar mais emprego no teu
país é incentiva produtores locais e
produtos locais a segunda dica que ele é
carne uma vez na semana e com certeza
vai tá contribuindo para ajudar nas
questões ambientais no desmatamento e
também o esgotamento dos recursos
naturais
a terceira dica tenta dizer não máximo
possível para os plásticos e
descartáveis
ah e claro que isso você vai ter que né
vai ter que comprar ou vai ter que ter
uma garrafinha de água ou então ser
igual igual eu pela muito café cima tem
uma garrafinha de café também para
consumir tá agora a quarta dica acho que
é quarta né fica quarta dica a quarta
dica vocês não querem contribuir para
isso
tá certo então incentive uma vez na
semana deixar o carro na tua casa e
tentar ir para o seu trabalho para tua
escola fazer as suas coisas usando o
transporte coletivo uma bicicleta ou
então uma carona alguma maneira de se
locomover mais sustentável
e quem tem última dica faça uma escolha
sustentável o natal tá aí você deve ter
um aniversário para ir a algum evento
que tal ao invés de consumir consumir
consumir vocês não foco conhecer e
conviver em dar experiências e da sua
presença a sustentabilidade é um convite
para você ter ser ao invés de ter
ah e tu disse que eu falei para vocês é
para focar em ser a melhor versão eco de
vocês eu tenho certeza que têm grandes
líderes grandes influenciadores grandes
empresários aqui hoje
o e são pessoas sustentáveis que
inspiram família que inspiram amigos e
que inspirou empresas a serem mais
sustentáveis e tornando a sociedade mais
eco muito obrigada ó